[Music]
hello there free to play games are
slowly taking over the triple a video
game world top quality creations without
an entry fee 2022 promises to be a crazy
year for new free-to-play games and as
long as you keep in mind they will try
to take your money through other means
like in-game items cosmetics and other
micro transactions you are good to go so
let's see what 2022 has in store for us
first up is rumble verse yet another
battle royale but wait this one has a
trick up its sleeve rumble verse is a
brawler royale all the moves are more
like a typical wwe match than a game of
fortnite ultra cartoony physics are used
with every building and structure being
scalable and vehicles are effectively
trampolines 40 players are freely
running around the city waiting to lay
the smacketh down on each other i've got
to admit it looks good to me
customization is a key selling point in
rumble verse with hundreds of items of
clothing body shapes and designer gear
to unlock and by allowing us all to
design our characters from head to toe
do what you like embrace your inner
furry become a member of team thick or
build whatever monstrosity you want the
options may be limitless rumbleverse
will be using open and paid closed betas
to perfect the game before suddenly
releasing completely free to play on all
platforms sometime in 2022
[Music]
next we have tom clancy's ex-defiant a
free-to-play arena shooter combining
numerous tom clancy worlds into one big
mosh pit ubisoft are taking the
realistic shooting from rainbow six
siege and merging that with the
superpowers of games like valorant and
overwatch each character in the team has
an ability which changes the game
slightly a hollow shield for defense an
armored turret for support and an
invisibility suit to sneak around all
these add to each fight making them more
tactical and also complete bedlam fans
of the division splinter cell and ghost
recon are all represented with factions
beginning with these four wolves who
have tank abilities the outcasts who
have healing abilities echelon have
night vision goggles and other tech and
the cleaners have crazy high dps
xdefiant and ubisoft should give us more
information in early 2022
game three arc raiders a co-operative
free-to-play third-person shooter where
you and your squad of raiders unite to
resist the onslaught of ark a ruthless
mechanized threat descending from space
taken from the book of the same name we
are a member of the resistance force
eliminating all the threats we can the
book has lots of time travel to contend
with but that's unclear if it's part of
the game too arc raiders is deliberately
set up to make going in alone highly
dangerous and only a cooperative squad
is the right way to play this a full
troop of your friends with comms all
playing completely for free taking down
giant alien spider bots or shooting
scutters out of the sky arc raiders
could be huge we'll see more later in
2022
out of nowhere someone is trying to take
on super mario kart take a look at kart
rider's drift this is actually not a new
game this series has been operating as a
free-to-play title with
microtransactions for many years over in
the east but now it's coming over to the
west challenge your friends regardless
of what platform they play on and enjoy
no barriers or paywalls to play the core
game created to be a completely online
game when new additions race tracks and
modes are added constantly the plan is
for the full game to release with at
least 100 carts and over 150 character
outfits showing us that customization is
once again the most direct way to get
into our wallets it remains to be seen
if there is a karting audience outside
of nintendo this could be the year cart
rider drift
[Music]
back in 2016 let it die released on the
ps4 and later came to pc an action
role-playing game with elements of dark
souls and a bucket load of grind to
progress mechanics fast forward six
years and that game world is being
expanded via death verse let it die
set in the format of a tv show
contestants fight to the death so yes
it's another battle royale this time
though it's melee focused we've seen a
whole heap of weird and wonderful
weapons from a superman dive with
oversized gauntlets and a deep sea diver
with a hammer bigger than your mum it's
a weird place this death verse release
date is set for spring so expect this to
first release on playstation around
march to june time and if the previous
game is anything to go by it will come
to pc soon after
here's a game i have high hopes for
multiverses let's get the most obvious
thing out of the way this is another
game which wants to be nintendo this
time smash bros a competitive platform
fighter that is totally free to play
although single player mode is here the
game is firmly based on team mechanics
for example batman's smoke bomb can hide
his allies steven shield can do exactly
that protect the squad and wonder
woman's kinky whip of truth can save a
falling friend effectively each
character has abilities to enhance each
fight multiverses takes warner brothers
properties and smashes them together
like arya stark from game of thrones who
could fight shaggy from scooby-doo it
doesn't make any sense at all but it
could be great if multiverses becomes
popular we can expect other warner bros
movies and games to be added the
potential is limitless from all the
games on the list multiverses looks the
most complete and ready to go in 2022 it
really could be the breakout
free-to-play game of the year
back over to ubisoft who has five
free-to-play games coming out over the
next few years this one is the division
heartland due out in 2022 we've heard
nothing since they first announced it
and we still don't even know if this
will be a third person shooter like the
rest of the division series we do know
that heartland is a standalone game that
doesn't require any previous experience
of the series as it will take us on a
new journey and a new perspective on the
universe many people are suggesting
heartland will be another battle royale
but there is no proof of this yet
whatever it becomes i'll be sure to make
a video on it later in the year so throw
me a sub if you'd be so kind i'd like to
get to two million and pretend my life
means something
[Music]
so that ubisoft game is uncertain so
let's switch to another one ghost recon
front line this one certainly is a third
person online shooter the blurb says
ghost recon frontline features an
advanced class system and a large set of
tactical support tools allowing for
complete freedom in strategic gameplay
with multiple ways to outsmart enemy
teams and win every fight like usual the
blurb that comes with games is so
confusing many people believe that this
game will be more like escape from
tarkov where a team of operatives go
into a map against other players and try
to come out again with new tech and
intel then rinse and repeat sadly this
game was thrown into limbo late in 2021
as the community was just not happy
ubisoft didn't have a good time with
free-to-play games last year so the beta
4 frontline was delayed until 2022 we'll
have more confirmation soon and the only
thing we do know is that it won't run on
last gen consoles on your pc ps5 and the
xbox series
many of these games are without a
certain release date right now so here's
a certain one for january pubg the
battle royale which was arguably the
first to make the genre a worldwide
phenomenon on january 12th it finally
goes free to play i don't think you need
me to break this down but without this
game we probably wouldn't have fortnite
so give it a try jump out of the plane
pick up a weapon or a frying pan and get
the vic roy by being the last to survive
i mean win a winner chicken dinner
hey you have you ever wanted to ride a
dragon then you should check out century
age of ashes it released on pc late 2021
and is coming to console in 2022 age of
ashes is a pretty intense fight or
flight survival game the game mode
scenes so far are three on three are six
versus six all all-air combat on the
back of dragons each class has a certain
play style wind guard phantom and
marauder with unique abilities too for
example the phantoms have a mine ability
and the marauders can wield frost bolts
a multiplayer dragon battle game who'd
have thunk it
[Music]
for the next bunch of games we're going
to go much quicker as most of these were
supposedly releasing in 2021 but they
never did when they do though i will
release a breakdown video more in detail
but for now we're going to rush through
it roller champions remember this game
back in 2019 we saw this and in 2021 it
was about to release and then suddenly
vanished the idea of the game is pretty
simple grab a ball throw it through a
hoop and each lap of the course you
complete determines how many points that
ball is worth the game was delayed for
extra polish to be added whatever that
means so we should see it in 2022 knives
out knives out is a popular mobile game
in the same vein as pubg and has been
coming to console for years it now has
2022 on its radar with the confirmation
that knives out extreme is confirmed and
it was confirmed by playstation it's
more battle royale you either like it or
you're absolutely sick of that genre by
now next blood hunt if you know my
channel you know blood hunt a vampire
focused battle royale was scheduled to
release on ps5 over halloween it missed
that deadline it was then promised to
arrive in 2021 and it's missed that
deadline too and now the new date is
spring 2022 so expect this between march
and june if you don't want to wait that
long it's also available on pc right now
scavengers another game i had such high
hopes for a post-apocalypse survival
battle royale with pve elements too
surviving the cold weather while slaying
falls looked insanely fun scavengers did
make it to pc in 2021 yet consoles are
waiting for the full release which comes
in 22. next caliber another one of the
games we hope to see in 2021 and like
scavengers it did release on pc the
free-to-play tactical military shooter
has a small but loyal fan base and in
2022 we should see the full release of
the game including next gen consoles so
watch this space
[Music]
and finally league of legends wild rift
with the exceptional arcane netflix show
bringing us so many league characters
many console players have been waiting
to try league of legends wild rift the
mobile version of the online battle
arena was due to come to consoles in
2020 but due to the outbreak we can't
talk about on youtube progress was
stopped and the release date for
consoles was completely taken away with
2022 here is it finally time to see
league of legends on console if not you
can always play on mobile and pc right
now so there we have it 16 free-to-play
games coming in 2022 well 15 in league
of legends wild rift are there any of
these you'd like me to cover in more
depth because i'm happy to do so just
need to let me know if you're watching
this before christmas please have a good
one but if not have a great year 2022 is
your year i'm adam you're awesome i'm
taking the week off woohoo see you soon
bye
[Music]